c'est fini marie-rose bletterie quitte
définitivement la salle d'audience après
22 ans en quête de justice
elle a eu peur avant le verdict plus
qu'au premier procès c'était beaucoup
plus difficile
la peur de ne soit pas condamné un même
peine et on a beaucoup parlé du viol du
heurt j'ai très peur qu'il ne soit que
le viol ne soit pas reconnue donc là
c'est la peine est confirmée c'est un
grand soulagement
quelques heures plus tôt maître nicole
se prépare à plaider une plaidoirie très
solide mais qui ne suffira pas à faire
douter les jurés
l'issue de ce procès s'était joué avant
au fil des auditions et des incohérences
de pascal jardin
après le verdict ce sont des scènes
frappante d'humanité telle cette
accolade entre myriam la soeur de
christelle et mickaël jardin le fils de
l'accusé
ou encore cet échange entre michael et
le policier qui a arrêté son père oui la
souffrance de michael le fils de pascal
jardin ils souffrent autant que nous et
des dégâts collatéraux et c'est ça sera
il faudra aussi qu'ils puissent se
reconstruire après tout ça ce soir le
dossier bletterie s'est refermée tous
pensent désormais à l'avenir à respirer
un peu et puis
le collier pour les autres dossiers de
l'association mais on ira jusqu'au on a
le dossier de carole soltysiak on a des
tas de dossiers on en a c'est 30 où il
faut qu'on arrive à les faire déboucher
de la même manière il n'y a pas de
raison que les autres familles n'est pas
non une réponse
il est essentiel que les magistrats qui
ont en charge ces dossiers et magistrats
de la région et puis elle magistrat plus
généralement sache qu'on peut sortir des
dossiers très anciens qu'on peut arriver
à des condamnations
hier soir ils étaient une trentaine de
l'association christelle à entourer
marie-rose bletterie car au delà des
dossiers criminels
cette longue histoire témoigne d'une
exceptionnelle solidarité entre les
familles des victimes